that you know what I was doing at 33  working in a liquor store really yes  really like 21. dude I was working in a  liquor store you're gonna be proud trust  me I'm always ready getting started wow  you're a kid I'm proud I'm proud you  should be you're really great artist I  know you think you're late and I'm  telling you you're not the thing that  you're deploying right now is a frantic  speed that lacks patience because you do  think you're late because you're looking  back at how you did it the way you  sustain it is to slow the [ __ ] down the  way you sustain it is to understand  you're just starting for all the good  that's happening in my life and all the  winning that people perceive that I have  I laugh when people are like think of it  that way because I genuinely think I'm  just starting you just have 20 30 40 50  real years of Hardcore execution you  just need to slow it down and you can't  make it about arbitrary things like  numbers